all right good evening everyone welcome
so we can start that's really good this
is when I remind you to turn off your
cell phones
so thank you and we are delighted to
have Lynn cook and Joan join us with us
here tonight and I'm here to introduce
the two distinguished guests here and
the list Center is honored to have Lynn
cook with us who is a renowned art
scholar and is a senior creative special
projects in modern art at the National
Gallery of Art in Washington DC before
her current position Lynn was a deputy
director and chief curator at the Museum
National centro de arte reina sofia and
madrid and she was the curator of dia
art foundation in new york from 1991 to
2008 she was the artistic director of
the 10th Biennale of Sydney and was the
coke curator of the Carnegie
international at the Carnegie Museum of
Art in Pittsburgh in 1991 Lynn has also
worked in various capacities at numerous
academic institutions including Yale
University Mammal Academy in Malmo
Sweden and Bard College in New York she
has been involved with Jones worth for a
long time and in particular when Lynn
was a curator at the DAR foundation and
presented Joan's
performance the shape the scent the feel
of things at DIA beacon in 2006 and Joan
Jonas has an acclaimed multimedia and
performance artists whose work who's
worked in video performance installation
sound text and drawing she is a central
figure in the development of the
performance art movement and to many she
is an icon the work that Joan and a
small group of mostly New York artists
began with the work that Joan and a
small group of most New Yorkers began
over 40 years ago first attracted
attention then broadened the
understanding of an arts community and
their contribution will use museums
today no longer hesitate to include
performance video or conceptual art into
a permanent collection Joan Jonas is a
New York native and she continues to
live and work in New York City Joanne
was a professor
the MIT program in art culture and
technology and so teaching at MIT in
1998 she is currently professor Merida
and the MIT is art culture technology
within the School of Architecture and
planning for her exhibition at the 56th
Venice Biennale she created an immersive
atmosphere with videos drawings sound
props and objects that sent the viewers
often to five different worlds five
rooms simply titled Bea's fish mirrors
wind and homeroom in an edition Joan
created three magical evenings in Venice
with the performance they come to us
without a word - it was the listeners
privilege to be involved in the project
and to support such an ambitious and
visionary effort
I believe that Joan now is busier than
ever and she currently has an enormous
exhibition at the mammal Koontz table in
Malmo Sweden titled light time tales an
exhibition that first was presented at
the hang of bacówka in neuron last year
and part of Joan's Venice Biennale
exhibition will be presented at the
Nanyang technical universities Center
for Contemporary Art curated by Buddha
Mehta bar was also who table met a bear
who was also the co-creator for the
Venice Biennale and was the associate
professor for visual art at MIT and was
a founding director of a program in art
culture and technology and many of you
saw the exhibition Joan Jonas selected
films and video 1972 to 2005 here at MIT
curated by listeners henrietta whole
dish we wanted to give context the new
work being created for venice by
presenting a cross-section of the works
that Joan made during 1972 to 2005 and
of course there are many people to thank
that made the exhibition the performance
and the talk here tonight possible and I
start with MIT we like to thank Philip
Khoury the associate provost for the
incredible support and also the enormous
support of president rice and Chris
Wright the first lady
dia del note Santos and now Dean -
Sarkis and probe
Marie Schmidt gave their support early
on to rally the MIT community we also
have to thank the US State Department
for the continued support of the u.s.
Pavilion it's really an important thing
offering up this important diplomatic
gesture to the world through art in
addition mit office of the president
office of the provost office of the
associate provost office of the Dean of
the School of Architecture and planning
mit program in art culture and
technology get immunised or boas and
Lila Kenny also MIT central development
team that were crucial in helping us
raise the funds and also the list
centers Advisory Committee and all the
staff members at the listless Center we
thank you very very much the lead
support for the pavilion was the US
State Department along with Helen
Frankenthaler Foundation and many more
individuals who rallied to support the
project including many who are in this
room tonight including members of the
Council for the Arts you guys support us
early on we're grateful for that Caryn
Gregg Aronson valaria and jean-jacques
de goof but d'arbeloff Audrey and Jim
Foster Patricia lavallee and Jeff Hager
Don Lucy Newman and Richard Lim Helen
and Bill pounds Taryn Rick stone dia art
Frank Williams Laurie McGovern and also
Sara and Sanders who also supports our
public art program greatly so a grateful
the opening week in Venice it really
felt like a celebration not just for MIT
but also for Boston and Cambridge us
rallying together and I was grateful for
all the different museum directors who
came to celebrate the Arts here in
Boston and Cambridge and of course we
remember Jane Farber and a contribution
to the project and to the list Center
but I had to single out Cindy and John
Reed for being there from the very
beginning and to help launch Joan and
her project
and lastly I have to thank Jennifer a
longtime association with MIT and her
lasting contribution to the arts and
also allowing the list Center to support
her vision and the ambitious project in
Venice
and with that I introduced John John or
someone cook thank you Paul
what we plan to do tonight is begin with
a focus on they come to us because as
Paul has said it was hosted and
organized I believe and because I would
argue too it has aroused such enormous
interest and acclaim it's been
remarkably well received and exceptional
project and I feel many of you will have
seen it that others will have not so we
were going to begin by showing some
stills from the installation in the
American pavilion and some short clips
of footage from the projections in it
and then we will talk for a bit then we
will show some more footage and so on
and this will take us through to about
15 minutes worth of time and then
there'll be a short bike and time for a
short time for questions before I break
so if we could begin with the first
images please say can we back up to the
very first one this is the American
pavilion and it begins here with Jones
bundle of tree trunks here and then you
would enter a series of rooms which Paul
just mentioned beginning bees the next
and the next and the next
and the next so this is we're looking
into every train and each of the
galleries had a V train with material
that spoke to the images and the
drawings in the room I included these
vitrines because I wanted to add more
information without saying it in words
and that's the reason for the vitrines
yes we're looking into the brain from
above the next so now we're looking at
one of the screens on which moving
images were projected next and again on
the screen and the next now we've worked
into the second gallery which was
loosely organized around water and fish
fish yeah the next and the next
looking again into the train and the
next now we're walking out of that
gallery into the central rotunda as they
married chandelier in the next and now
we're walking into another gallery and
completing the circuit the next the next
sorry oh I think that's a good fish room
and then sorry we've gone back and forth
so we get back into the Rotunda and the
next and the elderly was made in Murano
it wasn't no it was made I got the
crystals their old crystals in Venice
and we made it dimly we made it there we
had the frame and the mirrors the
mirrors because I was doing something in
Venice I wanted to do something in
Murano and the mirrors were all the
matters that you see were from made in
different ways from Murano
amara and the next so now we're walking
into wind when and these kites were made
in Japan I made them in a residency
program in Japan and the next and the
next
and the next
and the next and the next
and the next
and the next
and the next
and the next this is the homeroom yeah
sorry yes
and the final gallery yeah and the final
gallery yeah and the next and the last I
think the next slide is one more the
next and now if we could have the first
section of the moving images
well it's a good clip to have because I
think it shows us those the complexity
of the imagery and the way you're
constructing this in more sophisticated
more subtle more rich ways than ever
before I think for those of us who've
watched your work over time we can see
how you migrate certain modes of working
certain types of footage from earlier
pieces into new pieces in this
combinatory way we can see certain forms
of address to perception and to the
construction of images but before asking
about some of those things I wanted to
quote something you say in the very
beautiful book that was produced in
conjunction with this you say and I'm
quoting although the idea of the work
involves the question of how the world
is so radically changing I do not
address it directly and I want to ask
you about this directly well I don't
because I don't want to make a didactic
piece and also I feel like the audience
my audience is more sophisticated I
don't have to explain and this first
clip you showed in what sense it sets up
the idea for the whole pavilion which is
the fate of bees and and I was really
moved by a quote by an Icelandic writer
held there laxness about the miracle of
what bees do transmitting pollen to the
and making honey out of it and he said
there couldn't be a more miraculous
event even if intergalactic
communication were in order or something
like that he's very witty but he's also
says very seriously so that's what
inspired me to actually when I first
read that I thought about the bees so in
the very beginning each room has a
subject and one of the video projections
is about the subject of bees and the
other one is about the ghost stories
which run parallel
anyway but this one it does set up the
whole the idea of the piece I think
introduces it and with the bees
disappearing and and what that may do to
foodstuffs and life on the planet as you
say it's never didactic and you don't
point directly to charts or statistics
but we look at we come to the bees in a
way through a variety of different
perspectives different lenses the one
hand we see the six-sided like a
honeycomb structure but it's also that
these eyes are made up of many facets
they see differently from us and they
see in relation to this multiple spatial
dimension they think which is which is
interesting given the kind of multiple
spaces you then start to construct and
these the worker bees go out and they if
it's a work piece some bees go out and
they find sources of food and come back
and do this dance which gives the
coordinates and the distance to the
other bees so that they can then go out
and retrieve this material and was the
point at which where the children in
particular what first you see the bees
in the honey on the honeycomb they're
moving and one imagines maybe they're
involved in this dance and then you see
the children who seem to be learning it
or all making their version of it how
did you what did you tell them I've made
diagrams because the way we did this
particular part we found a beekeeper in
Brooklyn and visited him not the
children but myself and my assistant and
that's when I recorded all the hives and
all the bees and he he actually came to
the to the session one of the sessions
engrave a little lecture which I didn't
put on here about the way the the dances
the bees I think there are four dances
that they do which I find amazing I mean
that bees community
in that way and so I made little
diagrams and the children I gave each of
the children a little a little booklet
and and they and then they just simply
we had them move in those patterns which
are very simple they their patterns like
this over and over again the bees make
and that's how we did and that's what
you saw them doing and this is the first
time we've done a major production with
children that seems like a huge
challenge well in a way it was a huge
challenge in another way it was a
complete joy because it was so wonderful
to work with the children I did it in a
very simple way
I had workshops on Saturday afternoons
for about six weeks and the children
came just those Saturday afternoons
there was no time - when you say
workshop you think oh they developed you
know movements and improvise for hours
but no I had to have it completely
choreographed and set up before they
came in just I gave them tasks basically
because they don't have such an
attention span especially though the
little boys and the little girl would
immediately start to become distracted
with each other and that was a challenge
but the mothers came to so I always have
an enormous little audience of parents
watching and and so I gave them these
jobs and then they had very specific
directions and they took it very
seriously so that was very interesting
and did you show them footage so they
could see how they were going or what
there was never time to do that actually
and they didn't see the piece until they
all saw in Venice amazingly because
except for the two girls
the kids were all in the performance so
they were all able to see it and but
it's interesting to work with children I
don't have them act you know they just
behave and I think for me that's a way
to avoid certain things it's very
difficult but so one of the mothers
insisted on telling her daughter that I
had to say the same thing you're just
doing it
for Joan she never told her it was a
performance or anything like that in
order for him not to get self-conscious
mm-hmm so that's the thing you have to
be to watch in not having them act and
having them do tasks in a sense it takes
me back to how you started making your
own I mean I really everything I mean I
really began that way the New York in
the sixties the dancers and artists who
are making performances happenings
it wasn't about acting it was about
doing tasks actually task-oriented
performed and and everyday movement so
that's really how I began myself and
they're dressed in white which makes
them all similar but it also provides a
good projection screen yeah I want them
to personal I want them to disappear
into the projections and just quickly as
the projection the effects are made by
it's a double it's a back projection
screen so I played with there was a
projector behind and in front of the
screen so I played with those two
projections often plus a scrim so that's
how all the effects were created so they
were actually made physically they were
it's not about mixing in the canal
there's no specialist production no
which is something I've always believed
in Matt I always wanted to work just
with the material at hand and not I've
done a lot of special effects obviously
but in this there's no special effects
and just seeing the it was a new way for
me to work actually as you said it's the
double projection and you're using
different kinds of cameras now from well
and this in the piece in Venice I
because they use old footage I did have
several different kind of cameras
because cameras from the past and then I
used a GoPro but I hired a camera person
for this and so I don't even remember
what kind of camera
but there was a counter person there who
had a really good camera you have to
have a really good camera to record this
should we look at one more yeah if you
could play the next
science of spirits you don't see
anything where there's electricity once
the power went in they never heard
anything move or taboos I wouldn't walk
in the middle of the road the wind
opened the front door it was a beautiful
afternoon just like a choir the voices
came in mama used to go for a walk just
in the woods around and often she heard
music
my father used to hear voices from the
other side of life he'd go up in the
forest to his space there and he just
sit down and talked with his own father
my grandfather and others other people
in that world his people I can still
speak with my father he's a young man
now he comes with a beard now and
everything as I knew him and then he
changes to what he is a young man my
mother the same I borrowed a rope to
take my cow to pasture and I never gave
it back the Rope is hanging on the bars
it's bothering me you give the rope back
and you won't see me no more if you give
me a thousand dollars it would knock you
down you'd see compressed like
everything was pressing on you and I've
heard different fellows who rolled off
the road
my grandfather years and years ago saw
his track he thought it was a bear's
track and they followed it for about
four or five miles that was spring of
the year and there was snow on the
ground I've got a feeling that started
way back maybe somebody fired at him and
then he came to me inquisitive and I
didn't fire at him
maybe he got the idea he wanted to help
me out though several times he was out
in the woods looking at me I cut wood
one day and I cut about four loads for a
truck but my back or my arm was sore and
I wasn't piling it it was all spread
over the ground
way up and my father's old property okay
I went home at dinner I went back up and
it was all pile so nicely
honest to god I thought I shoot myself
this is crazy
there's no ten men could do it in that
time I just went back to Meco for lunch
and came back and it was piled so nice I
could just lay it in the truck and bring
it home that was so beautiful
well I was standing alone but I heard
walking ahead of me and I heard ice
break and I went after him and I
couldn't catch him and that walking into
my unclear I didn't catch nobody didn't
see nobody but the walking is do I could
hear the walking I could hear the clamor
of ice break he kept me on the road
so I I see this section as in a sense
being epitomizing the second thread that
runs through the whole project and
that's to do with the ghost stories
these are ghost stories from Cape Breton
from Cameron yes and most of the footage
is shot up there well the footage in the
landscapes are what is all shot up there
yeah and that's a place you've gone by
girl in the summers I go every summer
and there's a comment about when Alec
electricity comes we can see less and
it's as if the ghosts don't come anymore
we don't know they're around
what's your attraction to ghosts or to
these folktales and we see many folk
objects so things that look I've always
been interested in and work done by
untrained artists I mean we have it so
many names for it it's hard to know what
to call him folk art and so I collect up
there for instance
you find some of it no it's kind of
disappearing and since first going to
Cape Breton
in 1970 I became very interested
local culture and when we first went up
there in the 70s they still there was
some of the old people still who had
been there for you know some 80 years
and they still have these superstitions
which I've always been fascinated by
superstitions and these beliefs and the
superstitions come from Scotland so my
work has always been involved with
exploring mythology and and most
storytelling in a way which exists all
through art history in the paintings and
sculpture so in a way I continue in this
way
and the ghost stories I'm trying to
remember the first moment of thinking I
can't remember but I included the ghost
stories because of this the idea of the
animals and and all these things are
disappearing and it's interesting I just
saw a piece about children in New York
and they talked about death they're
slightly older children and the children
I worked with we never mentioned that or
any I didn't want to burden them with
with the subject matter but the pieces
partly and I wouldn't use this word
normally but just because I saw this
piece just now but the piece is involved
with this line between life and death
and what's happening in the world and
that's why I included children to
juxtapose what's happening and and the
fact that they are the ones that
experience it and how they see it and
they're just seeing virtual virtual
copies of of animals a lot and so the
ghosts represent for me the spirit of
all these things that is disappearing
and then I just simply on one level I
love the way okay Brett nurse tell
stories and the very simple everyday
language it just seemed to fit into this
piece when you um very early on you went
to create to look at Minoan culture in
66 or so and said something about going
to a wedding that was going on and
spending time and presumably with people
you didn't know but you could be part of
it and the in folk culture it was a sort
of everyday thing but everyone could be
part of it yes yeah I mean I was one of
those people from the 60s that wanted
the that kind of experience to go to a
place like Crete I lived in a village
for three months and that's why I was
able to go to this wedding that lasted
for three days up in the mountains and I
wrote we wrote up on donkeys
got thrown and and was wedding there
were people drinking getting drunk and
the bride and groom and it was an
amazing experience
very beautiful up in the mountains and
then things happening in each other
village is coming down going through the
village where all the men had been
killed by each other because of
vendetta's and things so I was just sort
of fascinated with being in a place like
that and to me well I was always
interested when I studied art history to
see how to go to the beginnings of
things like early Mycenaean and Minoan
how did things begin that's why I went
to Crete well I love the imagery and
also these little seal stones were they
this idea of the mother goddess of
course I was interested in the idea of
major alien air cultures and the mother
goddess but yeah how do things begin and
so that's probably my interest in people
who are untrained how do you begin with
no training you just begin and so when
you went to Cape Breton did it seem like
a coach of the peddles has sprung up
from immigration and it was yeah it had
the same fascination for me I just felt
immediately and then the music that
fiddle playing is very haunting and I
just simply loved it mmm got involved in
it and identifying with it and you see
that passing so it's about ultra passing
in the way and then there's in parallel
the ecological environmental shifts and
they're running in tandem yeah a little
bit yes
on the other hand I'm very interested in
it I don't believe I can't say I believe
in goes but I'm very interested in the
fact that people do and I thought
because these are all old stories that I
used but then I talked to a friend of
mine up there who's maybe in her 50s and
she told me about the ghosts in her
house you know so they still believe in
ghosts and people as you know people all
over the world believe in ghosts so I
think it's a very interesting phenomenon
of a belief system from the stories that
you extract or from the readings that we
none of the ghost stories strike me as
they're not vendetta's or vindictive
they're not horrifying and gory they're
actually kind of amiable ghost-like yeah
I didn't I thought there were two things
I thought about I didn't ever tell the
children the ghost stories but I also
didn't want to scare children you know I
didn't want to have scary stories and I
didn't want to have I read a lot of
ghost stories I got I got piles of books
and and we did research but I wasn't
interested in any of those stories I
really wanted everyday occurrences and I
liked the sounds that that you know the
ghosts always make they make they come
stamping up the stairs or they knock the
door down or they you know I like that
aspect of of the ghost that kind of
presence and the association with light
the lights the mysterious lights there
so I like the more abstract
ghost story mm-hmm and the narratives
that I hear their truncated we get
enough really extracts and parts enough
that we can sort of fill them in because
they're their types or their archetypes
and and that takes me to if we could
have the next image place to where I
think this probably begins in your work
oddly enough
well maybe not oddly with with
Commission to do a project for children
at the ICA and Philadelphia in 7676 yeah
yeah and you chose a story from Grimm
brothers did you go to portray the
juniper-tree yeah it's interesting like
the children weren't in the piece but
they're in the audience yeah I was
commissioned by the ICA in Philadelphia
I had dealt with myths before that thing
like that this was the first fairy tale
and it's a very grim actually I called a
friend of mine Susan how it was a poet
because it's a vast you know I said I
thought of doing a fairy tale I thought
which one it's a huge animal area so she
suggested that juniper trees her son's
favorite story it's a horrifying story
it's
it's it's one of these stories you can
trace back
I always traced my stories back to the
origins so you can trace it back to
Egypt and really yeah you can really try
because also you trace them across they
go a lot of these stories came across
Europe from Asia it's interesting anyway
so this is a story where they there's a
good mother and a bad mother and the the
bad mother kills the son and then makes
a stew out of him and feeds it as the
father it's a terrible story but this
son it was her son's favorite story and
when I when I so when I gave it in in
Philadelphia I say it was a Sunday
morning performance with the children
the mother is readied of course before
and they came up to me horrified and
luckily Bruno Bettelheim had just
written this book called the uses of
Enchantment in which he says that ghost
stories are teaching stories and they
teach children how to get through hard
difficult and scary times and so thank
God this and you'd then rewrap that
several times was the collaborative
performance and then it was the
performance in a slightly different
version so it went through some
transformations well I mean it's been a
long I've had a long career and when I
did the collaboration it was great I
collaborate with it was a very kind of
like a full of objects and kind of
acting out and symbolic things but I
thought I had to do this I have to get
closer to this material it was very hard
to enter into the character of these
well the bad mother was the most
interesting character and so I made a
solo piece in my loft which is the set
of which is now exists and I felt like I
got closer to the material when I could
deal with it on my own go have the next
image which is a also from the
juniper-tree yeah and in this did least
in one version you had an audio track
where you read the story all the
versions I had audio tracks but not in
the very first where the children yes I
Susan how read the first in the first
one but I developed an audio track with
music and is very elaborate like a film
score yeah what were you I was going to
ask you I suppose about recorded voices
spoken voice that your yours is usually
the only voice that's a live voice for
example the children don't say anything
and the voices of the people telling the
ghost stories are not people we see No
can you say something about how you
break narratives down or multiply voices
so we we have a distancing in a way and
we think about narrative structures as
much as we immerse ourselves in the
stories well I've been struggling with
the narrative for many years since I
first began to work with stories and
because it's a problem of course how to
translate a story into a visual I can't
really I can only say that I deal with
both the the text the visual elements
like material and it's like they're
physical things for me and it's like
arranging them in certain ways when I
started using my voice in this piece
that was when I started making audio
tracks very elaborate ones with the
reel-to-reel tape recorder and cutting
and I have to say I no one's asked me
that question exactly so but I'd say
that for me I'm not a dancer but my
voice is something that I'm interested
in develop I've always been I had to
learn how to speak and so I worked with
the Wooster group for a couple of years
and that was interesting in relation to
working with the voice in a different
way I think the voice is a very
important element it obviously I'm not
quite sure how to answer your question
except that I will say that and this
this is the version at the Whitechapel
Gallery
quite different but for the peace in
Venice I didn't want to be the only
voice so that's why I had other readers
it's just the way I didn't I was so
relieved not to be the only not to be
the main performer and and to have
mostly children and only appear very
briefly in this piece I did I think
working with children in their voices
it's much more difficult I didn't have
time to develop it I would have had the
children to speak but we didn't have
time to do that in the time we had
together because if the children start
speaking and maybe it takes us to the
shape descent the feel of things which
is a piece we don't really have time to
show footage but it's a piece that was
built in part around a lecture that a
revolver gave to demonstrate that he was
cured from his mental disabilities and
there's a person who in a sense plays
the part it's almost more theatrical
than yeah more like to conventional
theater a man yes so there's but then
the text is not coming is partly coming
from him but not always it's coming from
you it's coming from pre-recorded sounds
in that case the central script was
where the voids that Jose who played
Warburg spoke which was his lecture
there are many other elements about
Warburg's research and and work that I
wanted to include and I always work with
layers and so the voice becomes layered
there was Warburg there was Warburg's
voice and then there was my voice in
different ways pre-recorded and played
and then sometimes I spoke but very
little live and for instance there was
one part where you see melancholia and
then Warburg and another woman is
sitting in front of it and you hear my
voice
I'm Warburg took photographs in the
southwest
I didn't want to show anything any
representative representations of the
Southwest or the Hokies but I wanted to
include that information so I I just
recited the titles of the photographs a
voiceover to give another layer of
information so it's really it's partly
you would say about how it sounds and
musically but it's also about
information and how to how to put
information in into the piece how to
include information which the audience
then works to put together in their own
terms
it strikes me that in a way what you're
doing with text you then there was a
parallel movement in the way that you
used music from very early on you used
existing recorded music then you worked
with composers like Alvin Lucier who
made if I understand it correctly a
composition that you then you yes to
working with Jason Moran where both of
you start together in a way and it's
it's more of a dialogue or Jason's music
develops as you develop your yes the
performance mm-hmm
well when we worked at dia beacon it was
the most great experience because we had
six weeks to the first time I worked
with him six weeks we had to rehearse I
mean I had all the backdrops figured out
but then he came and together I
developed the movements as he was
developing the motifs and so we worked
together and that he plays something I
say yes no bla bla and but it's become
more and more of a dynamic relationship
over the years because that was in 2005
I started and now we just did this
together we did that he's much more in
the performance and he is in the
pavilion and the performance he's
playing all the way through the
performance and it's just become a
conversation that we have and a very
enjoyable it's very hard work but a very
enjoyable one because he's a jazz
musician and so and he's also extremely
generous person and you know likes to
improvise and I do too but I never had
somebody
encouraged me in the way that he does
and so that is what I like working about
working with Jason is this aspect this
seems a lot of cross-fertilization
because there are moments in this
performance and again 2005 where you
have a tray of bells and other things
and you make a sound pattern and what
sound structure which enters into a
dialogue with his so it's not that he's
providing he's working in one medium and
you're working in another if we can say
that that they're real crossovers and I
was extremely just for instance yes we
and we've developed that so that I
really for me that's just thrilling to
to work with a musician that way I would
have been I would have studied
percussion if I in an earlier time but
yeah so in a way you could say musical
symbols there are patterns and and like
motifs that are equivalent perhaps to
some of the visual symbols that get
constructed with with in each piece and
you've talked about symbols and the role
of symbols in the past it seems to me
that and the way they work as the the
nodal points of a narrative of the
narrative which is a fraction narrative
is been saying and partly a foul
narrative and the that kind of come that
component of your work is what develops
from 79 onwards and it's that that more
separates that if I can say from your
earlier work and from the the roots in
the downtown New York scene
a lot of a lot of discussions going on
about the even Reina the judge Sundance
the Lamont Young the music scene the
sculptors Richard Serra the process
artist early film there the Reuben
Gallery ultimate all of that but none of
them ever went in this kind of direction
and in a way that's incredibly it makes
you just spectrum in the owner counts of
your work you belong in a sense to this
extraordinary rich moment of downtown
New York in many many art forms and one
sees the cross-pollination but by the
time this starts to evolve you seem to
be way out on your own did that happen
of its own accord
was there ever a point you started to
think you were you'd gone somewhere else
from the very beginning I wanted to
break away from that and actually the
organic honey did I think in a way was
the beginning of that and I wanted to
but I really have consciously wanted to
develop my own language because it's
just like in an academic way I'd studied
art history and I knew when I went to
New York I spent you know before I start
doing stepping into performance sight I
did take workshops with dancers and
really searched that scene because I
really wanted to develop my own thing
just you know to go on to something else
and it was a natural it was in it was a
gradual break and I think I gradually
was able to to handle more complicated
and video was the first layering and
then I got more and more layered because
I want to say more and more in a visual
way and yeah it was very conscious but
it wasn't but as I was doing it I wasn't
thinking oh now I'm breaking away no it
was just a gradual development but it
began that way so it was from the very
beginning and desire yes I I remember
seeing the juniper-tree and
London 1979 I think but Minh in New York
by 77 79-77 I think Boise does the
coyote piece oh yeah and then 79 was the
retrospective at the Guggenheim and in
an odd way although you have very
different ends in your work and the role
of art-making
is different for both of you there is
some strange parallels that in a way I
can think of that those affinities as
stronger by them than with the coal
group of artists you started with well I
mean I I really always really liked
Boyce's work and was very interested I
never wanted to be influenced by him but
of course I saw the I did see the coyote
piece and I saw the Guggenheim piece
which is about honey and wax and all
that when I began the shape to
centerfield things I wasn't thinking
about boys because I wanted to choose an
animal that was indigenous not just to
the southwest but to many cultures the
coyote naturally one thing said boys you
can't get away from it but I wasn't
necessarily thinking but there is but I
suppose that there is an affinity I mean
he had a whole other system and world
completely different that I would really
stay away from but yeah because the art
historical framework that you're put in
is so strictly American it's so New York
centric except in addition then there's
this interest in older cultures and folk
culture and and it's it's in a sense
surprising because you didn't stay in
New York you went to create and you went
to Ireland and Iceland and it seems to
me of all know that ok Britain so you've
always had a foot one leg one foot
somewhere else well that was
maybe psychologically you could say
wanting to get away from home totally
but yeah I've always been interesting
I explored I was interested in other
cultures and I studied ritual I mean I
read all the books of that ritual when I
first began and I thought about my work
as ritual but you know my ritual in the
contemporary world because what am i
doing you know performance what is it
it's a kind of ritual and I explored
other cultures and I tried not I mean a
few times I quoted like them to looking
at Book of the Dead this drawing than I
did it was a copy from tribe of New
Guinea describing the how you get from
one life to death how you going to the
other world so I was always playing with
those ideas and consciously going other
places and and being inspired by those
places Japan for instance and it's
around this time that you also make your
first prints I think is it late 70s I
think so yeah yeah which precede making
drawings that are shown in gallery
context you hadn't up to that point and
thinking about it that's that's a holy
that that's very revealing in a way it
means that the first decade basically
you worked in tight everything was in
the service of performance installation
performance and then the print make this
printmaking which makes autonomous
objects and then gradually you find a
way to make make a form from the
insulation performance the new theaters
which become aware of entering the
gallery world with with works that grow
out of the all that that recapitulate
aspects of that what what was the lure
of the gallery world or what did
that was performance - intermittent or -
Commission's - rare or well I work
really hard in the performances and very
few people see them mm-hmm
so in a way the gallery world is a place
where more people and I always thought
that work like performance flows you
know my video works were shown on
television in the seventh day when I
began and then that went away so then it
shown it has to get shown someplace else
so it goes into museums and galleries
and I'm simply became after the show at
the state look in the nineties in which
I really concentrate on how do you make
installations I became interested in
that form and then simply interested in
having a situation that would stay
instead of two nights where you know a
few hundred people saw frankly I spent
out months working on something and I
wanted more people I want an audience
and also interest me I love making
drawings and so on so that's developed
well you've made an audience the show
maybe that's the moment to turn and ask
this audience do they have questions
sure so thank you I enjoyed the last
lecture you gave here and the cube I'm
interested in and it maybe it's a
question about influence I suppose and
it could be influences for you or it
could be others influenced by you or it
could be just I'm seeing an affinity
that has nothing to do with any of that
and it's about three individuals who I
find myself thinking about and one is in
the light of your what you just said
about ritual performance and I thought
about Patti Smith and how she performs
and how I since she understands her
performance a kind of ritual almost a
priestess creating a kind of space
that's how I understand that and so I
wonder you know if I've been influenced
by Patti
your connection if any with her I think
she's an incredible artist and I don't
have any I'm not only an admirer from a
distance but about her voice is great I
don't sing
she writes songs I don't write songs I
mean she's a poet and she know she's a
person I greatly admire but no the other
two when you talked about work as
opposed you know your instructions to
the people who they weren't acting they
were doing a job that reminded me of
David Mamet's approach to directing so
that's that's a second and then the blue
maybe should I go ahead and hold the
last okay the last is Robert Wilson some
of the images remind me very much of
some of his work so I would say I would
try not to be in front I mean David
Mamet I don't know his work I've heard
of him I know who he is
I've never seen one of his plays and
Robert Wilson of course I've seen his
work and I think that when you make one
can't help to say something like that
but I don't want to be influenced by
Robert Wilson who's a genius
definitely and he's influenced a huge
number of theater people in Europe in
America thank you but thank you for the
questions hi thank you both for the
interesting conversation I'm curious
about whether in preparing for this big
deal art affaire you did anything
differently from what you did for all
the years that you've been making art
and whether being there and having such
a big audience and such kudos changed
anything coming out do you do anything
differently now or are you pretty much
the same person as when you started well
no it was a very it was exist first of
all I want to say thank you for all the
people who supported me because it was
amazing experience to be able to do a
piece with so much support all along the
way so I could do it I really did
everything I wanted to do that was
amazing experience it was a hugely you
know you're focused upon it's a
tremendous focus the person doing the
u.s. pavilion and all the pavilions I
guess which was very scary I mean that
scare it made me very uneasy and the
stakes seemed so much higher than usual
because of that because of the focus the
spotlight and also that pavilion is a
real challenge it's a very
claustrophobic kind of not a very
inspiring space and it was a real
challenge to do something for that space
I had a great team it was very hard it
was very like work but totally I enjoyed
it very much
I really did it was like I think artists
love to work you know if they can do
their work the way they want to do it
it's the most the greatest experience
and I think this piece took me to
another place for sure
I didn't want to make it mediocre piece
I was really so I'm very glad it wasn't
totally mediocre but so it took me to
another place and did it change me I
can't talk about that now you know it's
in the first place is too soon in the
second place I feel kind of private
about about the way it's affected me I'm
still in that piece and still figuring
it takes me a while to figure out my own
work I don't totally I can't find words
for it and so I have trouble
articulating what exactly it's about
like I never today I mentioned the word
death for the bridge
I wouldn't have said it's about death
but I see that it's dwelling in that
area so I'm interested in extending
certain aspects of it now and and it put
me in a very good place that it was so
well received that's a very nice place
to be thank you hi John I basically had
a space similar question but I was
wondering you know in the context of the
Venice Biennial and I'm like some of the
other biennials around the world there's
this kind of nationalistic element and
do you throw that out the window or kind
of in line with like the pressure or the
anxiety you were talking about well yeah
that was very disturbed I have to say it
was something that disturbed me to
represent a country nation and also to
represent the US was very heavy thought
if you really think about it and I
talked to my friends a lot about it you
know how do I deal with this and who do
I represent what do I represent and
finally I thought of I represent my
friends my community and not just the
people I know but people I don't know
who are in that rather large community I
was I just said this in Chicago I felt
much better and when I was in Venice
working on the piece I had dinner with
sakis who represented Turkey and he's
Armenian and so he had a much harder
time than I had
but I mean in the end I was really happy
about it I mean because in the end is
just about what I said to your community
and it gives people a certain amount of
pleasure I see that yeah so I'm I'm just
curious when you were in Venice if there
were other aspects of the Biennale that
you found interesting provocative or
inspiring or disappointing like it's
such an amazing well one of the best
things about being in a group show for
me and I've been in a many group show is
the seeing the work of other artists
because you don't get to see that work
from day to day so I'm learning a lot
about what other artists are doing and
that is always really exciting and
fascinating of course it would take me
an hour to tell you all the things I saw
in Venice at the end the show there were
a huge amount of work to look at and I
saw a lot that interested me any of the
other pavilions oh you want me to
mention some pavilions I'm just there
was a beautiful film in the Belgian
pavilion the great pavilion intrigued me
the I haven't seen the Canadian pavilion
yet I'll see it when I go back yeah
there were other pavilions that I liked
I'm sorry to be so and then Venice
itself is a fascinating place but I was
very interested in many things that were
in Oakley's show of course it's very
hard when you're there working on this
working and then having all the people
that you know they're to see the show
actually it takes and you're exhausted
so I wish I could go back and see it all
over again frankly so thank you all for
coming tonight
thank win cook and John Jonas
you